heureuse de vous retrouver aujourd'hui
avec philippe juvin est d'abord vous le
comprendrez
au lendemain du 13 novembre et du triste
anniversaire des attentats au nom des
républicains redire notre émotion et
avoir une pensée bien sûr pour toutes
les victimes et leurs familles
hier encore d'ailleurs manuel valls a
rappelé que le risque était toujours
présent en france il a rappelé que ce
risque était élevé et il a rappelé son
souhait de prolonger l'état d'urgence
à ce stade je dis bien à ce stade les
républicains nous y sommes favorables
mais bien évidemment nous ne pouvons
nous contenter de cette situation
c'est pourquoi nous continuons à
regretter l'absence de mesures fortes
qui renforcerait la sécurité des
français
vous le savez à de nombreuses reprises
au niveau du parlement
nous avons fait des propositions qui
n'ont pas été entendus et nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui leur rappeler
alors que des milliers de djihadistes 3
à 5000 sont prévus pour un retour
prochain en europe et en france en
raison de l'affaiblissement de dèche
nous ne pouvons rester sans intervenir
de manière plus efficace
évidemment dans la politique de lutte
contre le terrorisme en france
nous voulons donc changer le droit et
l'adapter à la menace terroriste de
notre pays avec entre autres dois-je le
rappeler
aucun aménagement de peine pour les
détenus condamnés pour actes de
terrorisme et notre souhait d'une
création de centres de déradicalisation
pour lutter contre l'islam radical
il ne vous aura pas échappé par ailleurs
que nos candidats à la primaire ont les
uns et les autres des mesures qui ont
été présentées pour renforcer ce
dispositif que je viens de vous
au delà donc de cette actualité sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme qui est donc
toujours prégnant je souhaite revenir
sur la vie économique de notre pays et
sur une étude qui est ressorti cette
semaine en france
une étude qui provient de l'institut
molinari
cette étude est malheureusement un peu
passé inaperçu
pourtant elle fait elle aussi le constat
d'un échec supplémentaire en matière de
politique économique du gouvernement de
françois hollande
le résumé pourrait être la france vit à
crédit
plus de 50 jours par an en effet si de
nombreux français connaissent des fins
de mois difficiles
eh bien il faut le savoir la france
aussi car que révèle cette étude qui est
donc une étude qui fait référence à
l'année 2015
l'administration a dépensé à l'époque
donc l'intégralité de ses ressources en
date du 9 novembre soit 53 jours avant
le terme de l'année à cette date il nous
est donc précisé que les caisses du
trésor était vide et que le gouvernement
a dû emprunter sur les marchés
financiers pour payer ses fonctionnaires
et honorer ses engagements la france je
le disais donc vit à crédit plus de 50
jours par an une vingtaine de jours de
plus que la plupart de nos pays
européens
seule la grèce et le portugal font pire
que nous quel constat un résultat
d'autant plus édifiant que la france est
le pays le plus taxé d'europe
en clair malgré des recettes colossales
puiser dans les poches des contribuables
avec la politique fiscale des mesures et
que nous en ra veut donner ce
gouvernement avec le matraquage de 50
milliards depuis le début du quinquennat
donc ses recettes fiscales qui en 2015
et est de 428 milliard et demi
la france n'a pas réussi à couvrir
l'intégralité de ses dépenses
d'investissement et de fonctionnement
health qui se montait à plus de 500
milliards et dois-je rappeler qu'à la
naissance chaque français portent sur sa
tête si je puis dire
trente mille euros de dettes et la
tendance de fond n'est pour le moins pas
à l'embellie la dépense publique
progresse vous ne savez toujours un
rythme plus élevé que chez la plupart de
nos partenaires
et évidemment promet de s'accélérer si
l'on tient compte encore des dernières
promesses électoralistes de françois
hollande et de manuel valls
revalorisation du point d'indicé de
rémunération des fonctionnaires
généralisation du tiers payant etc
nous dénonçons donc les républicains à
nouveau cette politique inconséquente du
gouvernement gouvernement qui est drogué
à la dépense publique et donc qu'un
vraiment incapable de faire baisser le
niveau de prélèvement qui on le sait
bien sûr nuit à la compétitivité de nos
entreprises est réduit de fait le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages
un cocktail désastreux que nous avons
déjà dénoncée et qui expliquent vous le
savez en grande partie la quasi nulles
croissance que quand jce notre économie
malgré une conjoncture internationale
euro faible taux d'intérêt au plus bas
et coûts du pétrole bon marché
nous devons donc rompre avec ce cycle
infernal qui pénalise notre économie
fait porter aux générations futures
l'énorme fardeau de la dette et pour
d'où l'effort devra donc porter en
priorité sur la baisse des dépenses
publiques qui devront être massive dans
tous les domaines de l'action publique à
l'exception évidemment des domaines
régaliens de la défense et de la
sécurité intérieure et donc nous les
républicains nous proposons de restaurer
un cercle vertueux où dépenses publiques
et recettes publiques s'équilibre il
s'agirait tout simplement d'une
révolution dans notre pays où le tas et
souvent tenus pour responsables de tout
mais cette révolution vous l'aurez
compris est pour nous indispensable
merci pour rebondir sur l'exposé de
brigitte il y a cette semaine c'est une
information que je vous donne une
réunion du collège des commissaires
européens
et cette réunion est prévue de longue
date puisque c'est la réunion
traditionnelle qui permet à l'automne à
la commission européenne d'étudier de
juger la pertinence des projets de
budgets nationaux et 7
cette réunion a été précédée par une
interview une conférence de presse de
pierre moscovici
le commissaire chargé des affaires
économiques qui a fait un point sur
l'état économique de l'union et d'un
certain nombre de pays sans trop entrer
dans les détails mais suffisamment pour
qu'on comprenne ce qui va se dire sur la
france est un des éléments de l'exposé
de moscovici c'était le on le 9 novembre
2016 donc la semaine dernière est liée
au marché de l'emploi et pierre
moscovici a rapporté trois choses sur le
marché de l'emploi dans l'union
2 premièrement il a rappelé qu'il y
avait plus de huit millions de postes de
travail qui avait été créé dans l'union
depuis 2014
deuxièmement que le chômage avait baissé
de 2000 tr en 2013 2 11% à 8 et demi
pour cent en 2016 et troisièmement en
on attend 1,4 pour cent de chômeurs en
moins dans l'union et 1% encore en moins
en 2018 et donc ce marché de l'emploi
qui s'améliore considérablement dans
l'union européenne
et c'est pierre moscovici qu'il dit est
inverse de ce qui se passe en france ce
qui témoigne d'un décrochage
supplémentaire donc nous reprendrons
nous nourrir borderon cette question
quand la commission européenne
formellement aura donné son avis sur le
projet but de budget de la france
mais d'ores et déjà on peut dire qu'avec
la conférence de presse de pierre
moscovici la semaine dernière et bien il
y a eu une analyse très pessimiste de la
situation française
deuxième point d'or européen là aussi
sur des questions économiques
la commission européenne a fait la
semaine dernière une proposition que les
européens que les républicains jugent
tout à fait défavorablement vous savez
que la chine est entrée à l'om c'est
l'organisation mondiale du commerce en
2001 et quinze ans plus tard donc 2016
elle elle pourrait entrer dans le club
réservé de ce qu'on appelle les
économies de marché et la commission
européenne doit au nom des différents
états de l'union européenne dira si oui
ou non nous acceptons que la chine soit
traitée comme une économie de marché
qu'est ce que ça change et bien quand
vous êtes économie de marché
vous avez la possibilité d'échanger
librement sans barrières douanières
quand vous n'êtes pas économie de marché
ce qui est le cas actuel de la chine est
bien ou peu vis-à-vis des marchandises
que vous voulez importer
on peut ériger des bas rhin des
barrières douanières puisqu'on considère
que la concurrence n'est pas loyal et la
commission européenne ne souhaite pas
clairement dire qu'elle ne veut pas de
statut d'économie de marché pour la
chine nous pensons que la chine ne doit
pas aux républicains nous considérons
que la chine ne doit pas être reconnu
comme une économie de marché tout
simplement parce qu'elle ne l'est pas
qu'à des critères il ya cinq critères
qui ont été définies en europe pour
définir ce qu'est une économie de marché
et la chine ne remplit aucun des cinq
critères et donc nous considérons que la
commission européenne devrait très
clairement dire non la chine n'est pas
une économie de marché
manifestement la commission européenne
n'aura pas le courage de dire ça va sans
bien les fit côté dans des arguties
juridiques et éviter d'en parler en
disant oui en fait nous n'allons plus
reconnaître aucune qualité d'économie de
marché à personne ce qui évite de faire
de faire des plaisirs à la chine nous
considérons qu'aujourd'hui l'europe est
en grande difficulté avec d'une
concurrence déloyale des chinois si la
chine demain voit toutes les barrières
douanières européennes disparaître nous
pouvons perdre jusqu'à trois millions et
demi d'emplois en europe sont les
chiffres de la commission européenne
elle même et donc ça serait un suicide
la chine économie de marché c'est un
suicide pour l'industrie européenne et
pour l'industrie française et donc nous
sommes totalement opposés
la commission européenne est en train
de d'aborder une voix qui est une voie
dangereuse que nous contestons
absolument quand sera venu le temps de
l'alternance politique en france
les républicains remettrons sur la table
de l'union européenne cette question
fondamentale de la protection de nos
frontières nous voulons des instruments
de réciprocité nous voulons nous
protéger déjà alors que la chine n'a pas
le statut d'économie de marché nous
n'arrivons pas à nous protéger
qui peut imaginer un moment qu alors que
la chine bénéficiera toutes les
facilités d'une économie de marché alors
là pour le coup donc nous puissions nous
protéger nous nous protégerons encore
moins et ça serait absolument fou pour
l'industrie est suicidaire pour
l'industrie européenne
troisième point européen pour l'élection
donald trump qui a été largement
commentée vous donner simplement une
information qui vous a peut être échappé
qui date d'hier soir qui est absolument
ahurissante et en même temps peu
surprenante compte tenu de ce que à quoi
le gouvernement nous a habitués
jusqu'ici c'est qui hier soir les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
états de l'union se sont réunis pour
établir une position commune vis-à-vis
de monsieur trempé des états unis
d'amérique
antoinette européen 7,7
cette action est évidemment minimale
avoir une position commune
eh bien devinez qui était absent il y
avait deux ministres des affaires
étrangères qui était absent le
britannique ce qui est normal ils ont
déjà un pied à l'extérieur et le
français monsieur ayrault n'était pas à
la réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangère européenne pour définir une
position commune de l'union européenne
vis-à-vis des etats-unis tout simplement
il fait comme monsieur le foll qui ne va
pas au miso conseil des ministres
agriculture lui ne va pas au conseil des
ministres avec les ministres affaires
étrangères comment peut-on imaginer que
la france puisse peser en europe
si le ministre ne fait même pas le
déplacement à ces réunions aussi
importante
officiellement il avait une difficulté
d'agenda le dimanche après midi et
dimanche soir bien entendu on imagine le
type de difficultés des gendarmes ce
héros avait j'espère que le film a été
bon monsieur ayrault hier soir à la
télévision 4e informations d'origine
européenne avant de repasser la parole
je veux attirer votre attention sur un
point là aussi kim anh
malheureusement a été peu soulevé en
france je ne sais pas pourquoi vous
allez peut-être tout le monde aura
peut-être son explication c'est que
madame le pen se voit réclamer pour des
emplois que l'on peut qualifier
d'emplois fictifs manifestement si on a
bien compris la procédure
près de 340 mille euros par le parlement
européen qui considère qu'un certain
nombre de ses assistants parlementaires
n'ont pas travaillé dans les conditions
qui étaient prévues par les règlements
et les règles du parlement européen et
donc cela s'apparente réellement
manifestement à des emplois fictifs en
en tout cas c'est ainsi que semble le
juge et président du parlement
monsieur martin schultz président en
exercice du parlement européen
madame le pen madame mains blanches
manifestement n'a pas les mains
totalement blanche
elles sont un petit peu tâche et et
enfin on sait tout le mal que pense
marine le pen et le front national de
l'europe et au moins manifestement
l'europe leur sert de vache à lait voilà
sur les éléments européens et je te re
pas sa parole merci philippe m je
m'apprête à vous parlez moi d'un sujet
plus plus franco-français
la modification du statut de paris qui
est passé au sénat cette semaine mais je
ne peux pas aussi d'empêcher concernant
l'élection de donald trump est en effet
en rappelant ce que tu viens de dire
philippe l'inconséquence de l'absence du
ministre des affaires étrangères à la
première réunion européenne de pointé du
doigt aussi que notre président de la
république à ce jour apparemment ne
s'est contenté que d'un coup de fil au
futur président des états unis
si nous n'avons pas compris que donald
trump a mis au coeur de sa politique le
protectionnisme s'il a fait de la
défense des intérêts des états unis
sa priorité rappelons nous son slogan
america first
et bien si l'europe ne se réveille pas
et s'il n'y a pas de leadership européen
comment se préparer à ce qui nous attend
quand parallèlement tu l'a rappelé
l'ouverture du marché de la chine aura
des conséquences catastrophiques pour
les européens il serait temps évidemment
un que l'europe parle d'une voix claire
et forte
évidemment c'est ce que nous attendons
de l'élection présidentielle prochaine
qu'il y est enfin à la tête de la france
un président digne de nous représenter
non seulement sur le territoire national
mais au niveau européen pour enfin
porter les couleurs aux efforts d'une
france qui y croient et d'une europe
forte pour défendre ses intérêts alors
je le disais je m'apprêtais à parler du
statut de paris ça n'est peut-être pas
un sujet qui concerne la france entière
néanmoins ça n'est pas innocent ça n'est
pas innocent parce que le gouvernement a
présenté cette semaine au sénat un
projet de loi qui a été dicté sous
l'autorité de madame hidalgo maire de
paris un projet de loi tout simplement
inadmissible puisque la mesure phare de
ce projet de loi concerne la
réunification des quatre arrondissements
centraux de paris pour en faire un
secteur et ce sans justification aucune
puisque au moment où l'on parle du
discrédit ou de l'éloignement des
politiques avec les citoyens ça n'est
sûrement pas en est en écartant le
pouvoir de proximité que l'on arrivera à
redonner confiance
je suis élue maire du xviie
arrondissement
j'ai sûrement moins de pouvoirs que un
maire d'une commune de quelques dizaines
d'habitants c'est le statut de paris
actuel est ce que veut faire madame
hidalgo et de diminuer qui plus est
encore le pouvoir des maires
d'arrondissement c'est donc un coût qui
est donnée à la démocratie c'est une
magouille que nous ne pouvons pas
supporter par ailleurs ce tripatouillage
électoral je viens de le rappeler de
réunion de quatre arrondissements pour
certains d'ailleurs les mauvaises
langues le dirait serait pour eux assuré
madame hidalgo d'un parachutage plus sûr
en effet que le 15e arrondissement où ça
ne vous aura pas échappé à n'a jamais
réussi à se faire élire
mais ce qui est vraiment important c'est
de pouvoir redonner justement
du pouvoir au maire d'arrondissement qui
je le rappelle nous sommes élus au
suffrage universel et de faire en sorte
que ce ne soit pas l'administration
centrale qui décide en lieu et place de
nous est d'ailleurs normal que madame
hidalgo récemment effet la fermeture des
voies sur berge sans aucune consultation
qui plus est avec les communes
riveraines
est ce normal d'installer un camp de
migrants sans concertation aucune avec
les élus concernés d'ouvrir un parc
naturiste c'est sûr c'est notre priorité
quand on dépasse verte manque par
ailleurs pour tout un chacun
donc je voudrais ici saluer le travail
qui a été fait par les sénateurs les
républicains premier rang desquels
pierre charon qui a porté plusieurs
amendements qui ont été votés et je veux
ici le souligner car c'est très
important
c'est tout simplement l'enjeu de la
capitale des élus qui y sont et de la
vie des parisiens au quotidien ces
amendements qui ont été adoptées la
semaine dernière ont replacé le maire
d'arrondissement au coeur de la vie
municipale à paris nous disposerons donc
normalement de vraies compétences dans
des domaines clés qui sont le logement
l'urbanisme la propreté la gestion des
espaces publics
il est également prévu la création d'une
police municipale tout en gardant la
sécurité intérieure à la préfecture de
police
par ailleurs les axes de circulation
sera mis sous l'autorité de la région ce
qui paraît en effet logique quand on
voit ce qui vient de se passer tel que
je viens de l'évoquer à l'instant
concernant la fermeture des voies sur
berge où des milliers voire des millions
de banlieusards sont pris en otage tout
simplement pour se rendre à leur travail
l'alternative en transport en commun
n'existant pas suivant les destinations
d'où ils viennent
donc je voudrais ici saluer le travail
des sénateurs des républicains qui ont
bien compris où se situer la tente des
parisiens il appartient donc maintenant
à l'assemblée nationale d'être à la
hauteur
en effet des enjeux de ne pas avoir une
approche politicienne mais je le
souhaite
pragmatique je rappelle aussi que le
sénat c'est la chambre des collectivités
locales et que j'aimerai que à ce stade
pour une fois les mères que nous sommes
soyons également entendus
par les parlementaires et que le statut
de paris soit modifiée dans le sens de
l'intérêt des parisiens
je pense qu'ici les français
comprendront que j'ai pris le temps de
m'exprimer sur un sujet passer un petit
peu inaperçu au vu de l'actualité
nationale et internationale une un point
d'actualité nationale c'est la semaine
de l'employabilité des personnes en
situation de handicap
cette semaine est consacrée à mettre la
lumière sur une situation extrêmement
douloureuse pour la société française
c'est que les personnes en situation de
handicap sont exclus aussi du monde du
travail
on considère que le chômage les frappes
deux fois plus que le chômage des jeunes
les frappes deux fois plus et il s'agit
compte tenu des engagements que françois
hollande avait pris il ya maintenant
cinq ans d'un échec manifeste de la
politique du gouvernement
qu'avez vous fait vos engagements
françois hollande en matière de handicap
pas grand chose et en particulier dans
le monde du travail
on considère que seulement un quart
probablement moins d'un quart des
entreprises répondent aujourd'hui à
leurs obligations d'employabilité des
personnes handicapées c'est tout à fait
insuffisant et nous voulons mettre un
coup d'accélérateur à cette situation
qui est absolument inacceptable en
particulier comme vous le savez
les entreprises doivent doivent au
minimum employés 6% de personnes
handicapées dans leurs effectifs
on en est très loin et nous veillerons
si nous sommes choisis par les français
pour de nouveau diriger la france
est ce que le handicap redevienne enfin
une priorité nationale
je rappelle que la grande loi sur le
handicap 2005 c'est la droite
je rappelle que la scolarisation des
enfants handicapés
c'est la droite sous nicolas sarkozy je
vous rappelle que toutes les lois qui
ont fait progresser la cause du handicap
c'est la droite et la gauche
un conte fait des promesses mais n'agit
pas et c'est aussi un grand échec du
chômage que le chômage des personnes
handicapées
le chômage est un échec général pour
françois hollande lui-même
particulièrement quand ils le frappent
les personnes les plus fragiles et les
plus exposés c'est à dire les personnes
handicapées durant cette semaine
j'espère que le gouvernement prendra le
pouls de l'importance du sujet et de ses
insuffisances 13 très grande dans ce
domaine alors peut-être pour conclure m
un mot sur notre actualité chez les
républicains
la droite et le centre je voudrais à la
veille du premier tour
à j moins six des primaires en rappeler
quelques éléments de façon à ce que
l'information passe le mieux possible
entre autres pour ceux qui ont la
gentillesse de nous suivre sur facebook
et même si les médias vous êtes informés
en appeler les principaux et les
principaux faits d'abord nous réjouir de
cet événement historique pour toute la
famille de la droite et du centre en
france c'est une première une première
dont je pense que les uns et les autres
nous pouvons nous satisfaire du
déroulement et de la qualité des débats
nous avons d'ailleurs nos prochains
débats qui auront lieu je le rappelle le
jeudi 17 novembre cette semaine donc le
dernier avant le premier tour il aura
lieu simultanément sur france 2 europe 1
lcp et public sénat donc jeudi 17 quand
le prochain débat fall autre débat celui
entre les deux tours aura lieu lui le
jeudi 24 novembre sur tf1 et france 2
concernant le scrutin lui même je dois
rappeler donc qu'il aura lieu en
métropole donc les 20 et 27 novembre de
8h à 19h que la participation est de 2
euros
il faut venir avec la monnaie de sa
pièce si je puis dire que nous devrons
les uns les autres nous engager à signer
la charte des valeurs de la droite et du
centre et s'engager pour l'alternance
afin de réussir le redressement de la
france concernant les français de
l'étranger
le scrutin est électronique il faut
d'avoir d'abord avoir été préinscrits le
premier tour lui aura lieu du samedi 19
novembre à 19 heures au dimanche 20
novembre à 19 heures
concernant les dom tom l'élection elle
aura lieu les samedis 19 et 26 novembre
de 8h à 19h qui peut voter je le
rappelle bien évidemment il faut être
inscrit sur les listes électorales et
voter dans la commune où vous êtes
inscrit il faut être inscrit au 31
décembre de l'année dernière donc de
l'année 2015 et où avoir 18 ans à la
date de l'élection présidentielle de
où voter c'est là où les choses sont
peut-être plus compliqué puisque vous
n'aurez pas obligatoirement la
possibilité de voter dans votre bureau
de vote habituel
nous vous engageons donc aller sur le
site primaire 2016 point org ou en
tapant votre adresse vous aurez le
bureau de vote qui dépend de l'endroit
où vous habitez par ailleurs ne ligne a
été mise à disposition d'une ligne
téléphonique
c'est le 0 800 21 020 16
les bureaux de vote je le disais à
l'instant ce sont moins nombreux que
d'habitude puisque ce sont des bureaux
de vote qui ont été organisées par la
famille
républicains sous la haute autorité et
ils sont au nombre de plus de dix mille
10 1228
je voudrais à ce stade remercier les
militants les bénévoles qui à plus de 50
milles seront présents les 20 et 27
novembre pour tenir justement ces
bureaux de vote dans toute la france
enfin peut-être aussi une question parce
que elle est importante et nous là ça
nous a été posée le coût de ces
primaires c'est le mouvement
les républicains qui a rendu possible
l'organisation en faisant une avance sur
fonds propres de 5 millions d'euros à la
haute autorité
c'est l'autre la haute autorité
organisatrice de ces primaires et les
républicains seront remboursés à l'issue
de cette primaire
je pense que c'était nécessaire de le
rappeler puisque c'est la dernière
conférence de presse avant donc ce
premier tour et je voudrais encore ici
saluer le travail des uns et des autres
de nos candidats des équipes respectives
et de partir tous ensemble cette semaine
dans un esprit républicain
avant ce premier tour je vous remercie